this innovative approach driven by our
shared humanitarian impulse and made
possible by brexit freedoms
will provide
safe and legal routes for asylum
while disrupting the business model of
the gangs
because it means that economic migrants
taking advantage of the asylum system
will not get to stay in the uk
while those in genuine need
will be properly protected including
with access to legal services on arrival
in rwanda and given the opportunity to
build a new life in that dynamic country
supported by the funding we are
providing
the deal we've done
is uncapped and rwanda will have the
capacity to resettle tens of thousands
of people in the years ahead
and let's be
clear rwanda is one of the safest
countries in the world
globally recognized for its record on
welcoming and integrating migrants
later this year it will welcome leaders
from across the commonwealth and before
the pandemic in 2018 the imf said rwanda
was the world's fourth fastest growing
economy
we're confident that our new migration
partnership is fully compliant with our
international legal obligations
but nevertheless we expect this will be
challenged in the courts
and if this country is seen as a soft
touch for illegal migration by some of
our partners it is precisely because we
have such a formidable army of
politically motivated lawyers who for
years have made it their business to
thwart removals and frustrate the
government
so i know that this system will not take
effect overnight
but i promise that we will do whatever
it takes to deliver this new approach
initially within the limits of the
existing legal and constitutional
frameworks
but also prepared to explore any and all
further legal reforms which may be
necessary
because this problem has bedeviled our
country for too long
and caused
far too much human suffering and tragedy
and this is the government that refuses
to duck the difficult decisions this is
the government that makes the big calls
and i profoundly believe there is simply
no other option
and i say to those who would criticize
our plan today well we have a plan uh
what is your alternative now i know
there are some who believe we should
just turn these boats back at sea
but after much study and consultation
including uh with border force the
police national crime agency and
military maritime experts to whom by the
way i paid tribute for all the
incredible work that they do dealing
with this problem as things stand
it's clear
that there are extremely limited
circumstances when you can safely do
this in the english channel and it
doesn't help that this approach i don't
think would be supported by our french
partners and i've got to say to you that
relying solely on this course of action
is simply not practical in in my view
and i know of course that there are
others who should say who would say we
should just negotiate a deal with france
and the eu and we've made repeated and
generous offers to our french friends
and we will continue to press them and
the eu for the comprehensive returns
agreement that would solve this problem
we remain grateful to the gendarmes on
the beach for the joint intelligence
work and the cooperation that has
stopped thousands of votes
we would like to deepen that work and we
continue to believe that a deal with
france and the eu is in the national
interest of all our countries
but we must have our own framework
for full sovereignty over our borders
and we must find a way to stop these
boats now
not lose thousands more lives while
waiting for a deal that just doesn't
exist
and i know that there will be a vocal
minority who will think that these
measures are draconian and lacking in
compassion and i simply don't agree
there is no humanity or compassion
in allowing desperate and innocent
people to have their dreams of a better
life exploited by ruthless gangs as
they're taken to their deaths in
unsee-worthy boats and there's no
humanity or compassion
in endlessly condemning the people
smugglers
but then time and again ducking the big
calls needed to break the business model
of the gangs and stop these boats from
coming
and there's no humanity or compassion
in calling for unlimited
safe and legal routes offering the false
hope of asylum in the uk to anyone who
wants it because
that
is just unsustainable
there are currently 80 million displaced
people in the world many in failed
states where governments can't meet
their aspirations
in an era of mobile connectivity they
are a call or a text away from
potentially being swept up in the tide
of people smuggling
the answer cannot be for the uk to
become the haven for all of them
that's a call for open borders by the
back door a political argument
masquerading as a humanitarian policy
those in favor of this approach should
be honest about it and argue for it
openly
we reject it as the british people have
consistently rejected it at the ballot
box in favor of controlled immigration
we simply cannot have a policy of saying
anyone who wants to live here can do so
we've got to be able to control who
comes into this country and the terms on
which they remain and we must do this
in the spirit of our history
of providing refuge
and
in that way we can more than play our
part in offering sanctuary to thousands
fleeing persecution